foreign
before we begin I'm conscious that many
people following this hearing may not be
familiar with this court or with
proceedings of this kind so it may be
helpful if I explain a few points
Perth this court is the highest court in
civil matters for the whole of the UK
including Scotland it applies the law of
whichever part of the UK the case comes
from including Scott's law in Scottish
cases
it draws its judges from all parts of
the UK including judges who have served
for many years in the Scottish courts
it is based in London but has also sat
elsewhere in the UK including Scotland
secondly this court has a special
function under the Devolution
legislation
it is possible in some circumstances for
the Lord Advocate and her opposite
numbers in the other divorced
governments and the UK government to
refer legal questions about Devolution
to this court for decision
that is what the Lord Advocate has done
in this case
but the UK government argues that that
power cannot properly be used in the
circumstances of this case and that even
if it can be used for court in its
discretion should decline to decide the
question referred
so the first point of the court has to
decide is whether the question which the
Lord Advocate has referred is one which
the court can and should properly answer
if the Lord Advocate succeeds on that
point the court then needs to decide the
answer to the question which she has
referred which in essence is whether the
powers of a Scottish Parliament enable
it to legislate for a referendum on
Scottish independence
the third point that I should make clear
is that despite the political context of
this reference the questions the court
has to decide are limited to technical
questions of law the court will decide
them by applying legal principles
fourthly and finally the court will
require time after the hearing to
prepare its judgment
the hearing is the tip of the iceberg
we also have more than 8 000 pages of
written material to consider
therefore as is usual it's likely to be
some months before we give our judgment
Lord Africa thank you my Lord good
morning good morning
this is a reference of a dilution issue
made under paragraph 34 or schedule 6 to
the Scotland Act 1998.
the reference begins at ef3 and
paragraph 34 of schedule 6 is at ef3 359
which is in volume one of the
authorities
the reference seeks the Court's
determination of the question
does the provision of the proposed
Scottish independence referendum bill
that provides that the question to be
asked in a referendum would be
should Scotland be an independent
country relate to reserved matters in
particular does it relate to the union
of the kingdoms of Scotland and England
paragraph 1B or schedule five and or the
parliament of the United Kingdom
paragraph 1C or schedule 5.
going to adopt the following approach to
my submission
firstly I propose to explain the reasons
for the reference
secondly to draw the Court's attention
to materials considered to be
particularly important to the Court's
consideration
thirdly to set out my position on the
question of jurisdiction of this court
and respond to the Advocate General
submissions on that issue
on that particular point last week I
filed a copy of my speaking notes so
that the court could have the detail of
that submission to avoid the need to
turn up every reference
I do not understand the filing of that
note to have been opposed and the
treatment of that will be a matter for
the court
next I would propose to consider the
terms of the draft bill
thereafter address the legal framework
within which the question should be
answered and the principles to be
applied by the court
and lastly discuss the arguments that
support the question being answered in
the affirmative and those that support
the answer being in the negative
so my I begin by explaining the reasons
for the reference to the court
[Music]
to exercise the power refer to refer
confer to me by paragraph 34 are set
down in the reference that paragraphs
two to six that's at the electronic
folder page five through to six
and also in my case at paragraphs 19
through to 24 at the electronic Pages 43
and 44.
this is a power that has not previously
been exercised by Lord advocates
and I make this reference exercising my
own rule as Lord advocate in line with
the rule that I've been given under the
Scotland Act
however I am of course a minister of the
Scottish government and it is well known
that the Scottish government's policy is
that a lawful referendum should be held
in this case I concluded that in the
particular circumstances it was
necessary and in the public interest but
the question should be referred
I submit that this court has
jurisdiction to accept the reference and
it is in the public interest that is
answered by the court
killer circumstances are
firstly the Scottish government has been
elected on a Manifesto commitment to
hold a referendum on the question of
Scottish independence in the course of
the current session of the Scottish
Parliament
a manifest a commitment to hold a
further referendum has been approved by
the Scottish electorate several times
since the 2014 referendum
the history of contemporary political
debate on Scottish independence and of
the Electoral and constitutional context
in which that debate has taken is
described by me in my case at part three
of the case particularly paragraph D
onwards at page ef-52
as
Miss in 2019 UK general election a
majority of Scottish MPS were returned
on a Manifesto that supported a further
Independence referendum being held
with reference to that my case at
paragraph 73.
and in 2021 the Scottish general
election a majority of mstps were
returned on a Manifesto commitment to a
referendum on Independence again I make
reference to that in my case at
paragraph 76 at AF 62.
therefore the issue of Scottish
independence is alive and significant
one in Scottish electoral politics
and the Scottish government wish to
introduce a bill in the Scottish
Parliament to provide for holding for a
referendum
as is well understood the question
whether such a bill would be within the
competence of the Scottish Parliament is
contested
and has been contested since the Advent
of devolution
the history of the debate on that
question is summarized in my case
the question of the competence of an
independence referendum was considered
in the UK Parliament during the passage
of the Scotland bill
I make reference to that in my case at
length at paragraph 48.
and that electronic Pages year 53-56
and there's also references made and
comments made by other academic and
other commentators
at paragraph 24 electronic 44 of my case
Lord Mackay drummer Doom predicted that
it would become a festering issue
in my submission he has been proved
right
it is an issue that I invite this court
to finally resolve
introduced to and pass by the Scottish
parliament are within the Scottish
parliament's legislative congressants
the Scottish ministerial Court
which is a tab 117 electronic folder
6443 supports those safeguards
the combined effect of section 31 of the
Scotland act 1998 and the Scottish
ministerial court is that a minister who
wishes to introduce the proposed Bill
cannot make the statement required under
section 31 unless the Scottish Law
Officers have cleared the bill for
introduction
I would not be able to clear a bill in
the terms of that appended to the
reference
that is because as I have explained in
the reference I do not have the
necessary degree of confidence that the
bill would be within competence to
enable me to do so
nevertheless I consider that the
question of law raised by the proposed
bill is one which is genuine and
unresolved
I do not consider that is this in the
public interest that on an issue of law
but this exceptional purpose public
importance to the people of Scotland and
the United Kingdom that I should in
effect be the Arbiter
it is not constitutionally appropriate
that a law officer perform such a
function
only this court can provide an
authoritative ruling and provide
certainty and Clarity to the Scottish
government the Scottish Parliament and
the electorate
for all these reasons I have concluded
that it is in the public interest that
this court should be asked to do so
so can I set a little bit more of a
context
before the court
and look at some of the materials
I intend to spend some time no more than
an hour looking at materials that are
before the court that I consider are
important to understanding the context
for bringing this reference and for the
Court's determination of it
on the commitment of the Scottish
government to a referendum on Scottish
independence I would refer the court to
a document Scotland's right to choose
dated 2019
it's at tab 108 and the summary is
included at electronic folder number six
three two three
eleven through to 13.
and uh in that document the Scottish
government concluded
that there had been a material change of
circumstances since the 2014 referendum
namely the outcome of the referendum of
the UK's membership of the EU in 2016
and the impact on Scotland
I also refer to the Scottish national
party election Manifesto of 2021.
tab 112
it begins at the electronic folder
number 6350
and the commitment to the referendum is
at page 660 and 66 1.
this is the basis on this on the S P
contested
2021 Scottish Parliament general
election
thereafter on the existence of a genuine
unresolved issue of law I would refer
the court to the debates on the Scotland
bill in 1998.
significant extracts from that are
included in my case at paragast 49-51
electronic folder pages 53-55
and they are reproduced in tab 72 to 74
of the authorities beginning at PhD 72as
that's at volume six
I don't need to go through all of the
detail but the first that I would point
to is an exchange between the Secretary
of State for Scotland Donald MP and
Michael Anka MP in the Commons on the
12th of May
1998 and that is that electronic folder
page 3728
of course all stages of this bill were
taken in line with Convention as to
bills of constitutional importance on
the floor of the house
and questions were asked whether a
referendum in the union was reserved
and Mr Jew responded that constitutional
change was reserved
Mr ankram wasn't satisfied with that
answer and asked the question again
and Mr Jewish responds focused on the
effect of a referendum
he said if one assumes that this is a
way of changing the Constitution no it
is not in the power of the Scottish
Parliament to change the Constitutional
Arrangements
Scotland will of course have a right to
enter into any debate about these
matters in the United Kingdom Parliament
and there will be Scottish
representatives to do so
that is as it should be
didn't we expect to play a very full and
proper part in debates in the United
Kingdom Parliament on behalf of their
constituents
the point was taken up again by Dominic
grieve MP and Mr Jew further responded a
referendum that purported to pave the
way for something that was ultravirus is
in itself Ultra viewers that is a view
that I take and one to which I will hold
but as I said the sovereignty of the
Scottish people which is often prudent
Aid
and is still there in the sense that if
they vote for a point of view for Change
and mean that they want that change by
their vote any elected politician in
this country must very carefully take
that into account
I do not believe that they will vote for
that change or that there is enthusiasm
or a wish for that change we shall no
doubt argue about debate and analyze
that many many times
I should also point out that there is a
contribution in this debate by Mr
salmond Mr Alex salmon named p
and the answer to his question doesn't
necessarily illuminate the question
however it is relevant to note that Mr
Jewish responds is that when Mr salmon
should attempt to persuade the people to
vote for candidates who support his
point of view on the need for a
referendum and there is a degree of
mockery that the SNP only have five MPS
this is of some relevance to the issue
of political mandate previously
discussed
it would be said by the SNP that is done
precisely what Mr Drew suggested it
should do
then please see the House of Lords
debate on the 21st of July 1998.
Lord Mackay of drummer Dune was
advancing amendments dealing with
referendums and the competence of a
referendum on Independence
his contribution is at Pages three seven
three two and three seven three three
he said
notwithstanding the argument explained
by the Secretary of State in another
place and repeated by the Lord Advocate
on second reading I believe that it
would be perfectly possible to construct
a respectable legal argument that it was
within the legislative competence of the
Scottish Parliament to pass an act of
parliament authorizing the executive to
hold a referendum on the issue of
whether those who voted in Scotland
wished Scotland to be separate from the
UK
it would be perfectly possible to
construct an argument that it would
assist members of the Scottish
parliament in the discharge of their
devolved legislative and executive
duties to be aware of the thinking of
the Scottish people on that very
important issue
Lord Sue was unequivocal in his response
and to take his response a little short
he did see that if the parliament passed
an act to hold a referendum about
whether the union should continue
it would thus clearly be legislating in
relation to a reserved matter of the
Union
any such act would be about the
continuation of the union and therefore
would be beyond the parliament's
competence and would not be law
what page is that please so Lord Sue's
contribution is that page
ef-373-3737 thank you 3738 thank you
further
then on the question of unresolved issue
of law
it is relevant to see the views
expressed by legal academics including
Cormac mccamley yes but is it legal
which is in Tab 7 tab 67
at ef-3670
this rehearses more briefly the
arguments now being put before this
court in this reference without reaching
a firm conclusion of what the author
considers
ought to be the answer the question now
referred
in addition Gavin Anderson Christine
Bell Ailee mccartell the independence
referendum legality and the contested
Constitution Widing the debate at
ef-3680 tab 68.
responding to the UK government
consultation that said that it
Independence
outside competence authors consider the
question less straightforward than as
suggested by the UK government and that
a plausible case
can be made out that such a bill would
be lawful and that is at
ef-3681 tab 68 a summary of the various
academic views is set in the footnote to
paragraph 24 of the case at ef-44
law
resolved
section 30 order made in 2013 following
the Edinburgh agreement between the
Scottish and UK governments
terms of that order are ambivalent on
the question whether absent the order it
would be within the legislative
competence of the Scottish Parliament
reference there at me to ef-2164
and to see article 3 of the order at EF
-2168 both of which are tab 36
this provides simply that paragraph one
of schedule 5 does not reserve a
referendum of the kind provided for in
that article
and then I'd also wish to draw the
Court's attention to the materials on
the history of referendums in the UK and
their effects and say something about
the status of referendums in the general
constitutional framework
I deal with this at part three section
one of my case at ef-63 onwards and at
paragraph 78 to 80 of my keys
Pages 63 through to 64. I set out an
overview of the role and use of
referendums within the United Kingdom
and I would highlight the following
points which emerge from that discussion
the referendum as a constitutionally
legitimate device was recognized by
dicey at the end of the 19th century
although it was not until 1973 that the
modern use of the referendum began
dicey saw the referendum sitting above
parliament in the hierarchy of
constitutional decision makers
uh I refer there to dicey the referendum
1894
23 National Review in page 65 which is
at tab 62.
page 3582 of the electronic folder
there is no consistent practice in
respect of the use and legal effect of
referendums the House of Lords
Constitution committee twelfth report
in the session
2009-2010 referendums in the UK tab 100
electronic folder page 5100 made that
statement
my case refers to the 1973 border poll
in Northern Ireland
in 1975 UK referendum on continued
membership of the eec
the 1979 referendums on Scottish and
Welsh Devolution
the 1997 referendums on Scottish and
Welsh devolution
the 2011 referendum on changes to
Virtual system for elections to the
House of Commons
the 2014 Reverend on Scottish
independence
and the 2016 referendum on UK's
continued membership of the EU
from this we know referendums may be
self executing in that legislation
authorizing the referendum provides for
what is to be done in response to the
outcome of that referendum
see my case at paragraph 80
referring to the Parliamentary voting
systems and constituencies act 2011
which required the minister to bring
into force or repeal certain provisions
of the ACT depending on the outcome of
the referendum on proportional
representation
section 6 of the 2011 Act is at tab 30
of the authorities at electronic order
1236
that is tab 30 in volume 2.
and referring to the Devolution
referendums of 1979 as being similarly
self-executing where the threshold for a
yes vote was not met the irrelevant acts
of parliament were repealed see for
example section 85 of the Scotland act
1978 which I refer to electronic Boulder
1051
such self-executing referendums remain
of course subject to the principle of
parliamentary sovereignty unlike in
jurisdictions we read referendums have
particular constitutionally prescribed
role and function
if a UK Parliament wished to to it it
could pass legislation to prevent the
outcome of a referendum from taking
effect
more commonly however no provision is
made as to the consequence of any
particular
outcome from a referendum
that was the case in the Scottish
independence referendum act 2013 which
provided for a referendum on
Independence
it was a position adopted by the
Westminster parliament in the European
Union referendum act 2015 and it is the
position in the in respect of the draft
bill
a
non-self-executing referendum invariably
has political consequences but in law it
has no effect they are entirely advisory
and in that respect I referred the court
to Moon against the Lord Advocate at
paragraph 47 which is at Tab 8
electronic folder 6941 which is a
statement of course of Lord neuberger
finally
I know that in relation to the proposals
for the Scotland bill
that would establish the Scottish
Parliament and in respect of which an
advisory rather than a self-executing
referendum was ultimately held Donald
dure characterized the intended
referendum as being a test of public
opinion and is a matter of establishing
consent
and the reference there is
ef-3727 and the date that he made that
statement was the 21st of May 1997.
finally on the materials at the proposed
bill is at ef-13
the bill is complete in all respects
material to this reference
there are minor tactical matters that
would need to be dealt with Before the
bill could be introduced
the question referred for the answer of
the Court concerns only section 2
subsection 2 of the proposed bill
he said about the draft bill at this
stage it is addressed in more detail in
the submissions and whether or not the
bill is or is not within the Scottish
parliament's legislative competence
jurisdiction
my position my is I'm making positive
submissions on the jurisdiction of this
court to hear this reference and they
are set out at part two of my case
beginning at ef-40
the submissions in response to the
advocate General's case so far as
relating to jurisdiction of the court to
hear and to determine the reference are
set out in the separate speaking note on
jurisdiction
first on the substance of the question
referred I seek authoritative guidance
from this court and have presented both
sides of the argument
I do take a positive position though on
jurisdiction in my submission this court
does properly have jurisdiction and
should answer the question referred
so on the positive case for jurisdiction
paragraph 34 of schedule 6 to the
Scotland act which is at ef-359 volume 1
tab 1
is straightforward in its terms
provides that the Lord Advocate May
refer to the Supreme Court any
Devolution issue
the proceedings
Devolution is defined in paragraph one
to schedule six
and it includes any other question
arising by virtue of this act about
Reserve matters
and that you can find that at ef-322
volume 1 tab 1.
I contained that the question referred
is the question arising by virtue of the
Scotland act about the reserve matters
of firstly the union of the kingdoms of
Scotland in England and secondly the
parliament of the United Kingdom
I refer to electronic folder page number
183
it is a question that arises by virtue
of the Scotland act because firstly it
is about Reserve matters a reserved
matters exist only by virtue of the
Scotland Act 1998.
by virtue of section 31 of the Scotland
act
1998 electronic folder one three four
it is necessary for the member
introducing a bill to make a statement
that the bill is within legislative
competence
the member in making such a statement
must reach a view on a question of law
in the case of a government bill that
statement cannot be made unless the bill
has been cleared by the Law Officers
the requirements then of section 31 and
of the ministerial Court have been
acknowledged by this court
in the uncrc reference case paragraphs
12 and 73.
that's an electronic folder 914 and 933
is in volume 1 tab 15 at page 904.
I see that in combination these
Provisions support the principle of
legality
moreover they support the view that the
question to which the reference relates
arises by virtue of the Scotland Act
paragraph 34 or schedule 6 allows
certain Law Officers to obtain
authoritative legal guidance from the
court on the operation of the dilution
scheme where the law officer in question
considers that appropriate to seek such
a definitive ruling
I have explained why I consider it to be
necessary and in the public interest to
obtain from this court at this time an
authoritative ruling on the question
affair
in short I see this there is a genuine
issue of law that is unresolved which if
if it is resolved could permit the
proposed Bill to be introduced
however absent a ruling from this court
that the draft bill would be with
incompetence I could not clear the bill
the issue is one of exceptional public
importance to the people of Scotland and
the United Kingdom
the issue is directly relevant to the
central manifest or pledge that has been
endorsed by the Scottish electorate
I have mentioned at paragraph 24 of the
case that there is academic commentary
on the issue which expresses different
views and I would add to this there is a
risk that even if I cannot clear a bill
to be introduced
by the Scottish government a bill could
be introduced by an individual member of
the Scottish Parliament and that
reinforces the to my in my respectful
submission the importance of obtaining
an authoritative judicial ruling from
this court at this stage
in those circumstances I'm seeking legal
certainty at this stage
it is the responsible course and my
assessment it is in the public interest
as I'm noted in my case paragraph 25
onwards at ef-44 I acknowledge that it's
appropriate to say a word about the case
kittens Against The Advocate General
which is the volume 1 tab 14 at page
ef-880
the Judgment of the inner house in the
case of kittens does not answer the
question referred to this court
I do not consider that the reasons why
the court considered that the case
brought by the pursuant kittens was
academic that applies to this reference
nor did I consider that standing
keatings it's inappropriate for me to
make this reference
in particular I consider that in the
current context the reference involves a
question that is now of considerable
practical importance
that's reflecting the language of the
Lord president when he contrasted the
keating's case with the position in
Whiteman
and that's at keating's page
ef-899 at paragraph 54.
the issue doesn't arise for me in the
abstract it is a live issue
so far as paragraph 34 of schedule 6 is
concerned I deal with that in my
response to The Advocate General but
note that no detailed submissions were
made to the court in keatings in respect
of paragraph 34 references
I acknowledge that the previous Lord
Advocate submitted that a paragraph 34
reference could not be made during the
passage of a bill but that is not the
circumstances within which this
reference arises
nothing then said by the Lord president
in keatings could be said to preclude a
reference by the Lord advocate in
circumstances such as this
so I might then turn to the detail of my
speaking notes on jurisdiction and
discretion artists and I'll take the
court through this and as I say I hope
that it assists in taking us through
this lengthy and in a sense very
technical argument which makes
significant reference to statutory and
provision and peace law
this this this response responds to The
Advocate General's case at electronic
folder page 488 a paragraph four and
Pages six through paragraph six through
to 46. Pages 89 to 103 in which The
Advocate General contains that this
reference is not within the Court's
Jurisdiction under schedule 6 of
and what part of schedule 6 paragraph 34
of the ACT
and alternatively should not be
entertained at the Court's discretion
schedule 6 paragraph 34
confers on the Lord advocates
Advocate General Attorney General and
attorney general for Northern Ireland a
power to refer directly to this court
any Devolution issue that's an
electronic folder page 359
the only qualification on that power is
that the Devolution is not the
Devolution issue is not the subject of
proceedings
schedule 6 paragraph one at page 322
states that for the purpose of that
schedule a Devolution issue includes a
subparagraph f any other question
arising by virtue of this act about
reserved matters
accordingly
the Lord Advocate is entitled to make a
direct reference to this court
pursuant to schedule 6 paragraph 34
which
paragraph one F where two conditions are
made firstly there's a condition
question rather a conduct question about
reserved matters and secondly it arises
by virtue of the Scotland Act
I see these conditions are satisfied
there is a question about Reserve
matters named the question identified
for this court and the reference and it
arises by virtue of the Scotland act
the exercise by the Lord advocate of my
function of advising the Scottish
ministers with the purposes of section
31 1 of the Scotland Act
in my submission
the satisfaction of these conditions are
set out clearly in my written case
at paragraph six through to 18. at pages
40 to 43 of the electronic folder could
I just ask you a question about the
qualification in paragraph 34 on page
359 any Devolution you see which is not
the subject of proceedings on my
understanding that's because elsewhere
in the schedule there's a regime for the
ability of proceedings are on foot one
that the law office officers to to seek
rulings on Devolution issues so
paragraph 34 is is a sweep up it's
intended to broaden it beyond that
regime
yes that's I agree with that milord and
that's how the term was described in the
notes and clauses a sweep up provision
almost yeah thank you
so The Advocate General has two distinct
arguments on jurisdiction against his
position
the first and principle argument is that
even if the two conditions set out above
are satisfied there is an implicit
exclusion in the terms of paragraph 1f
such that it does not apply to questions
relating to bills or draft bills
and that's at the I meet the reference
there to The Advocate General's case at
that point
his second argument is that the two
conditions set out in paragraph one AF
are not satisfied on their own terms
and these two arguments then I address
in term
firstly that uh the
um the conditions are not met
The Advocate journals essentially
implied limitation arguments
The Advocate journal's first argument is
premised on the assumption that the
conditions of one if are satisfied in
terms but that despite the Apparently
broad scope of the power to refer a
question pursuant to
schedule 6 paragraph 34 Read With
paragraph one F that power cannot in
fact be used for a question about a
reserve matter relates to a bill or a
draft bill
the reason the Advocate General gifts
for this implied limitation is found at
paragraph 24 of his case
where it said that allowing the power to
be used in circumstances such as the
reference which rendered the provisions
in section 33 for referring bills passed
by the Scottish Parliament unnecessary
the nub of that reasoning is that it
would be surprising if Parliament had
set up such a carefully calibrated theme
in section 33 and the surrounding
provisions and yet simultaneously
intended that scheme to be rendered
unnecessary by the discretion afforded
to the same officers to refer a bill
outside it
the short answer to the advocate
journalist submission is that I am not
by this reference seeking to refer a
bill at all
section 33 of the Scotland act makes
provision for bills passed by the
Scottish Parliament to be referred to
this court
but this reference concerns a question
about proposed legislation that has not
been introduced to the Scottish
Parliament and which currently cannot be
cleared by me for introduction
leaving aside the distinct questions as
to whether the reference of such a
question is hypothetical or premature
that I come on to address that there can
be no objection to the reference of the
grounds of inconsistency with section 33
since that section is not engaged and
may never be engaged
this is a question about proposed
legislation
indeed The Advocate General does not
contend that the reference is
inconsistent with the terms of section
33
I see he cannot plausibly do so rather
he takes the weaker position that
allowing a reference in these
circumstances would render the section
33 procedure to referral bills
unnecessary
however recognizing the entitlement of
the Lord Advocate to make references at
a pre-legis stage would not render the
power of a lord Advocate to do so under
Section 333 unnecessary
still less the power of The Advocate
General or the Attorney General to do so
pursuant to section 33
these circumstances of the present peace
that led to the reference being made are
highly exceptional and I set out these
in my case
absent such exceptional circumstances
concerns about whether legislation
relates to reserve matters may be
expected to be raised through the
mechanisms provided through the Scotland
act including section 33
. I see two particular situations
demonstrate the undoubted continuing
importance of section 33 even a schedule
6 paragraph 34 permits a reference to be
made in the present circumstances
firstly who your lord Advocate is able
to clear a bill it would not be
appropriate for a reference to me to be
made by me pursuant to paragraph 34
because no issue of law would need to be
termed determined at that stage in order
for me to discharge my function and for
legislation to be introduced by the
parliament
section 33 however would nonetheless
provide an important power for me and
other Law Officers to refer the
provisions of the bill to this court if
doubts about whether they are within the
legislative competence justify seeking
an authoritative determination following
the passage of the bill by through the
parliament
secondly section 33 has the obvious
importance where bills are amended
during a passage to include Clauses that
may be outside of competence
which Provisions would not have been
subject to section 31.
that is the provision that leads to the
statement or clearance by Law Officers
or where the process of legislative
scrutiny identifies concerns about
whether particular Clauses are within
competence
I see that there's a further answer to
The Advocate General submission that
section 33 provides an exclusive method
for raising Devolution issues relating
to legislation is that it's not
consistent with the express provisions
of schedule 6 paragraph 34 schedule 6
paragraph 180 read with 34 expressly
permits the Law Officers to refer acts
of the Scottish Parliament directly to
this court
The Advocate General recognizes us at
paragraph 17 of his keys but doesn't
confront the difficulty it pauses in his
argument
he states that schedule 6 at paragraph
34 allows Law Officers to refer acts of
the Scottish Parliament to this court
which for whatever reason were not
referred under Section 33.
the section 33 process is not an
exclusive process for referring
Devolution issues relating to
legislation to this court
that undermines The Advocate General
submission that paragraph one if should
be read as implicitly limited to
questions that do not relate to bills or
draft bills
in addition The Advocate General also
placed his Reliance on the explanatory
notes in Scotland act in his written
case
however
in Imperial tobacco
Lord hope explained that the explanatory
notes were prepared in 2004 by the
Scotland office and have no more weight
than any other post-enactment commentary
as to the meaning of the statute
they provide new support for The
Advocate General's case
on the contrary the explanatory note to
schedule six paragraph 34
emphasizes this amplitude
it says this power enables all officers
to refer any various question to the
judicial committee if it is not already
the subject of judicial dispute
likewise the explanatory note to one F
provides examples of situations swept up
by its terms clearly identifying it as a
catch-all or sweep up provision
contrary to The Advocate General
submission the explanatory notes to
sections 33 and schedule 6 paragraph 34
take the matter no further do you have a
page number for that explanatory note
sorry so the explanatory note is at page
ef-379 379 yes and I make reference to
that in my speaking my Lord at page 26
uh paragraph 34 subparagraph two we can
watch indeed
um
we go
I'm wondering
whether
[Music]
um
in in the party's arguments the the
ministerial code may be given more
significance than it really deserves the
under under section 31 of the Scotland
Act
um
a person in charge of a bill
oh
on or before the introduction of the
bill
state that in his view the provisions of
a bill would be within Medicine of
competence
um
now
the person in charge of a bill may very
well not be the Lord Advocate you know a
group in the case of a bill of this
nature it would be some minister in the
Scottish government
I presume yes
um
and
that person
in order to make the requisite
would require legal advice from somebody
and obviously the Law Officers are the
um
the authoritative source of of legal
advice as far as the Scottish government
is concerned is it my right so yes that
is exactly right my Lord
I see
but it so happens the ministerial code
formalizes that in a document that's of
a an administrative character it's not a
piece of legislation in this joke
um
but but leaving aside the the argument
about
um section 33 references of bills for
the moment everyone leaves that out of
out of the picture
um
if the person in charge of a bill
uh
is not clear as to whether the
SE Provisions would be within
legislative competence or if the person
from whom he would receive advice about
its legislative competence isn't clear
um
I wonder whether there's any problem
about saying that that would be a
question arising that the competency
build would be a question arising by
virtue of this act yes I agree with that
milord the the requirement for the
certificate rest with the minister
introducing the bill and the so the
whole issue about legislative competence
arises by virtue of the ACT yeah so the
minister
who's proposing the bill has to
consciously and responsibly apply their
mind to the section 31 test as a matter
of law the minister is not bound by the
Lord advocate's advice and there may be
circumstances in which the minister
could properly take a different view
however that view would really require
to be underpinned by rational
on a rational basis and a view reached
in good faith and
even though the ministerial court is
there and it requires the bill to be
cleared by the Lord Advocate before the
statements made there's no doubt that
the whole issue of this or whether where
this issue arises arises by virtue of
section 31. yes by virtue of is a phrase
of a statutory definition that's right
which includes under yes
well I think The Advocate General makes
a point that I'm introducing a
self-imposed barrier by virtue of the
way in which I've looked at matters and
applied the ministry record and for that
reason it doesn't this issue doesn't
arise by virtue of the eyes but it
plainly does because the whole question
of legislative competence has to be
addressed by the minister presenting the
bill to Parliament and he or she could
not do so if he didn't consider it was
with incompetence
you just said they they couldn't do that
unless they considered it to be within
competence
but
what is it that prevents them from
taking a different View
from the law offices if the Law Officers
say
I don't believe this is in legislative
competence but the person in charge
has the view that it is
what is it that stops them from saying
thank you for your advice but I am
prepared to make that statement
that would be a significant departure
from the way in which government
operates currently but there is nothing
as I said as a matter of law the
minister is not bound by the Lord
Advocates advice and there may be
circumstances where they could properly
take a different view but that different
view has to be based on a sound
rationale and reached in good faith and
the the enormous that Ministers of the
Scottish government take advice from the
Law Officers who are Scottish ministers
and it would be an unusual circumstance
for it to be reached that the minister
didn't accept or agree with the law
officer's advice but in in principle
really mixed a reasonable point
okay and could I just check
on students uh one indication of the
point that you've just been making not
to my lord lord read
um as I understand the position that
you're adopting the Devolution issue
that arises in a case such as this you
say
um goes to whether a bill is within the
legislative competence of the parliament
and that's legislative potentially
legislative competence under any of the
heads in section 29 2 that's page one
one two nine so
um it's not just confined to reserve
matters it would
um could be in relation to breach of
restrictions in schedule four and so on
yes but the the issues here are
particularly the issue in this case is
the equation of a reserved matter of
course yes no the reason that I'm I just
wanted to check that that is the way
that you're putting it because we're
going to come on to an argument as I
think from to James about
um bifurcation of issues that you can
get
a reference which wouldn't resolve all
matters
because
you're concerned with Reserve matters
because in fact as I understand your
argument
um a reference under paragraph 34.
the coptics about a Devolution issue if
it's from the Devolution issue is
specifically about the legislative
competence of the parliament is capable
of encompassing any or all of the
matters in section 29 2
in other words I think that bifurcation
problem may not be such a problem as as
was suggested in the written argument
well I think I come on to deal with
bifurcation and I could possibly come
back to that yes exactly I just wanted
to check that I was understanding you're
arguing correctly yes
program
yeah so I was I think
big question that the Lord Jade was
asking me about section 31 I'm just uh
I'll come back on paragraph 34. I think
it does relate solely to reserve matters
I'll come back on the point that my Lord
seals has made
an answer
yes
the point where I was wanting to explore
really was
um in relation to the argument which
James makes in his in his written case
um that really the the connection with
the Scotland Act is not sufficiently
direct because it's mediated through
internal practices of the Scottish
government reflected in the ministerial
code
um but the uh to the point I was wanting
to explore with you was was whether
really the number of the matter is
um is is that where there is uncertainty
on the part of the Scottish government
of a responsible minister in it as to
whether a bill would be within
legislative competence then
um that issue of competence would be an
issue arising under the ACT which you
might want to refer so far as you
competently can but you're you're still
but you are are you're not limited by
the the fact that references
under paragraph 34 can only be of
devolutionists yes that's right and and
your
um
your whether or not the matter could go
any wider and in terms of the definition
of devolution issues in paragraph one of
schedule six you're confining yourself
to the um the issue of Reserve matters
that's right yeah yeah so so I think you
have to accept that though that
that if there were room for a question
about competence on another basis such
as
impinging on legislation which is
protected against modification yes you
wouldn't be able to refer that is no
that's exactly right yes
yeah
you said a little while ago you referred
to the possibility of a an individual
member not a minister
introducing a bill along similar lines
as the bill you're referring
could you just clarify
whether you say
that
the the that would be then the person in
charge of the bill who would have to
make that statement yes
but I think you were saying they would
not need to seek the advice of the Law
Officers because the ministerial code
does not apply to them
they could just State their view yes
could you just clarify whether if that
were what were about to happen do you
say that you would have a power to refer
the question under paragraph 34 in that
situation
I'll come back I'm not sure about I need
to think about that point and I'd come
back with a particular answer on it
but I think what would be helpful to
know is that um a member's bill is a
public bill introduced by an individual
MSP
and the MSP in charge of the bill has to
be has to make the statement that the
bill would be with incompetence in their
View and that wouldn't require taking
advice from the Lord Advocate government
legal advice
the bill also can be introduced with a
positive or negative statement on
competence by the presiding officer
and the Lord Advocate Advocate journal
for Scotland and the Attorney General
can refer a bill which is considered to
be outside competence to the Supreme
Court as with any bill after the bill
has passed so there is a mechanism
within the Scotland act to allow for a
private members bill at a later stage
after introduction to be referred in
accordance with the statutory scheme
so it's just a different procedure but
there is mechanism under the act for a
reference after the bill has been
presented and has passed through
parliamentary procedure I would be
interested to your answer as your answer
if
um someone who is not a minister
was introducing proposing to introduce a
Bill had stated that in their view it
would be within legislative competence
you or another law officer disagreed
with that do you say that you would have
power to refer the bill before it was
introduced
yes I'll I'll consider that point uh
against the fact that there is uh
procedure within the eyes
for the appropriate reference to be made
in accordance with the legislative
provisions of the act and it might be
that in that situation that should be
the course that's followed but I'll take
I'll take that point and come back on it
I think I was dealing with
um
I was dealing with the explanatory notes
and notes and clauses
and I got to I think paragraph 35 of my
speaking Awards uh
16 of my speaking notes
uh The Advocate General also refers to
the notes and clauses document produced
during the passage of the Scotland Act
which are said to clearly indicate a
lack of intention on the part of
parliament to include questions about
bills outside of the section 33 process
the Lord Advocate accepts that the notes
and clauses are an invisible Aid to the
construction of the Scotland Act
on the basis however of The Advocate
Journal submissions
is that like the explanatory note the
notes and clauses document emphasizes
that schedule 6 paragraph 34 is intended
to allow any various question to refer
to the courts but unlike the explanatory
note the notes and clauses refers to an
exception a very question that has
arisen in proceedings on a bill before
the Scottish Parliament and The Advocate
General relies on this reference to on
the reference to this exception
in relation to notes and clauses I see
that the document does not however
assist the advocate journal's argument
if it does anything it provides
assistance and supports the Lord
advocate's position
the present reference has not Arisen in
proceedings on a bill
and doesn't relate to a bill currently
before the Scottish Parliament
thus the single exception identified in
the notes and clauses to the power to
refer to this court pursuant to pagar 34
doesn't apply to this reference
moreover the material part of paragraph
1A was not included in that subparagraph
at the time of the Scotland's Bill
introduction or when the notes and
clauses document was produced that was
produced in January 1998 and the
relevant wording of one F was introduced
by Amendment later in October of 1998.
The Advocate General also makes a series
of submissions offers written keys at uh
pages 94-96 to which I would make
specific response
at paragraph 25 he relies on the fact
that schedule 6
paragraph one does not refer to a bill
in any form or at any stage
this is correct
but it is irrelevant given the broad
amplitude of one if
as I see its nature is as a sweep up
clause and the fact that the Lord
Advocate has not referred a bill
uh 25 2 he also relies on an observation
in kittens
um page ef-901 that only a provision of
Act of the Scottish Parliament can be
outside competence
this is a variation on The Advocate
General's contention that their
reference relates to hypothetical
question and that it's premature
I'll respond to that in Part B later but
in short my answer is that a question
relating to a reserved matter has arisen
under the Scotland act and giving my
responsibility to advise the Scottish
ministers on draft legislation prior to
introduction
the issue is not hypothetical it's not
premature for it to be resolved
The Advocate Journal relies on
explanatory notes and notes and clauses
documents and I've referred to these and
thereafter he goes on to state that I
have not provided an explanation as to
why section 334 mandates that any
reference pursuant so section 33 1
relating to Bill shall be made within
four weeks of passing a bill or four
weeks after post-reference approval
standing pursuant to standing orders
made pursuant to section 36 5.
and I see one obvious explanation is
that this is intended to minimize
disruption to parliamentary proceedings
by stipulating that references under
section 33 relating to bills or
provisions and bills should be made post
passage in the prescribed period
the present reference since it relates
to an issue that has arisen before
legislation has been introduced doesn't
frustrate or affect such a rationale
thereafter The Advocate General contains
contains by reference to comments of the
Lord present in keatings
that this section 33 reference procedure
would be rendered redundant or it would
be a recipe for chaos if a reference
could be made in the present
circumstances
however at paragraph 61 of kittings the
Lord president was referring to a quite
different situation namely the quarter
session or in principle the sheriff
Court having jurisdiction to entertain
applications about the VDS of bills
during a passage prior to Royal ascent
thus the Lord president stated that it
would be a recipe for chaos if third
parties could bring challenges to the
views of Provisions in bills in the
court of session or the sheriff Court
during the passage of the legislation
it was moreover expressly by reference
to the possibility of Law Officers being
able to make such applications to the
quota session of the sheriff Court
during the passage of legislation that
is lordship stated that the refuse
procedure under section 33 would be
rendered somewhat redundant
I see that these remarks are simply not
in point in the present reference
firstly it doesn't engage the
jurisdiction for the court of session or
share of Courts and secondly is not
concerned with provisions of a bill
during its Passage through the Scottish
Parliament
so do you accept them that once a bill
has been introduced
the section 33 mechanism supersedes
uh the one f
but there are certain circumstances that
I could foresee that one if we've come
to plea
uh particularly thought about that where
a Bill had been presented
um
I just
thinking on that
yes so having thought about that matter
in particular my lady
uh what I'd see is I wouldn't wish to
rule out the possibility
of that happening although I would
accept that generally it wouldn't be
appropriate and I've thought of examples
in that respect
it might be for example there's an issue
of urgency but on which there is
political steel meat into Parliament
because for example parliamentarians are
divided in the issue of whether the bill
is within competence
another example might be where urgent
legislation is important for National
Security and it would be contrary to the
public interest whether to be a delay in
the determination of an issue of
competence before the legislation came
into effect
so fundamentally and ultimately it is a
question of the rule of law
the boundary of reserved matters is a
question of Law and is a question
ultimately for this court
and if the rule of law and the proper
functioning of the parliament required
an issue to be resolved and I cannot see
that the Lord advocate of the day would
not consider a reference
but we are I think in this circumstance
my lady talking about hard to conceive
and inherently exceptional circumstances
well just thinking in terms of the
question posed at page nine and
following on from Lord Reeves
observations
the the essence of the case as far as I
understand it is that
um
who are it's impossible for you to
advise in the present state of the law
is to whether it is or with it within or
without competence
and I was wondering whether the question
should be
slightly rephrased namely
is it possible for the old Africa to
advise that or is it possible for the
minister to make a section 31 statement
that
um
if that is the real issue I think I
think we have to go back to the terms of
section 31 yes
um and just reminding myself of precise
terminology in section 31.
um
set page
134 an electronic bundle
and says that
in terms of section 31 which is between
us pre-enactment safeguards that were so
uh so what page numbers again sorry
ef-134 Millard 134.
section 31 is one of the pre-registered
safeguards and requires for scrutiny of
the bills for legislative competence and
protected subject matter
and it provides us a person in charge of
the bill shall owner before the
introduction of the bill to the
parliament state that in his view the
provisions of the bill would be within
legislative competence of the parliament
so they have to actually that that is
what is required in terms of the
statutory certificate before the
introduction of the bill so that we have
to be able to see that it would be
within competence
and I think that's the point that my
Lord read was making about the fact that
this issue does arise by virtue of the
terms of the acts I think the the
minister making a statement as a public
law duty to make the statement on a
rational lawful basis and as I say that
is informed by the advice of the
officers of the day
so in this case I couldn't create a
certificate in terms of those stereo
reports and in addition because of the
state of the law the person in charge of
the bill couldn't meet good whose
obligations or her obligations in terms
of section 31 of the ACT
you know I suppose you can contrast that
with subsection two where the presiding
officer can say yes
their view whether it does or it doesn't
it can still be determinative about the
process it's just the view but that's
right you're emphasizing that in
subsection one it is determinating
whether the process can continue yes and
it is an important Safeguard and one
that's of that's required to be taken
extremely seriously for all of the
reasons rehearsed in the uncrc will case
and others
so
I
I was then going to move on to
um
yeah so I I'm making reference to The
Advocate General submissions uh to
um in his case at paragraph 25 6.
that the Lord Advocates power to refer a
matter to this court pursuant to
schedule 6 paragraph 34 is limited to
reserve matters and doesn't embrace all
possible issues of legislative
competence I see that's correct but
irrelevant and I Point again to the
sweep up provision in schedule 6 1A
which relates only to questions about
Reserve matters and doesn't extend to a
number of other issues that could arise
under the Scotland act not only schedule
four issues I think what we've been
touching on but also for example
compatibility with the European
convention on human rights that's but
that's no indication that there should
be a restriction on the circumstances in
which a reference can be made with a
reserved matter does arise as in this
case
so if there were questions in relation
to a draft bill on other grounds and
Reserve matters
couldn't be referred under this
procedure but if it were then introduced
there would ultimately have to be
a a use of the section 33 procedure
that's exactly right so they would have
to be considered pre-introduction by the
Law Officers of the day and by the
minister presenting the bill and
thereafter during the parliament to
parliamentary process these issues would
be open for scrutiny under the
pre-enactment provisions that we've
touched on
thank you so in relation to the can I
just ask on on that
do you offer any sort of explanation why
Reserve matters should have been singled
out in that way
why there was a difference made between
preserved matters as opposed to others
in the process
uh I could think about that and uh
theorize on that at a later stage I
think the the point is for an
opportunity under the Scotland act to
bring forward as you know as quickly a
good and quickly way as possible these
issues for the determination by the
Supreme Court to enable the smooth
running of the Scotland act so there's a
whole series of stages at which
legislation can be considered unfair to
the Supreme Court under the Scotland act
but there must have thought to have been
a necessary opportunity for an issue
like this to arise and for authority to
be granted rather an authoritative
ruling from the court to be given over
an issue that's concerning Law Officers
of the day so it makes it's a just
another process another way in which the
law offices of the day and the Scottish
ministers who seek to govern accordance
with the rule of law can seek an
authoritative ruling from the court
another another way in which we can
make sure that pre-enactment safeguards
are properly good use of I mean I was
wondering whether there's any basis and
maybe there isn't for saying that
Reserve matters are if you like
particularly fundamental to the
Constitutional uh Arrangement created by
the Scotland and because they go to
the reservation of matters to the United
Kingdom Parliament as opposed to the
Scotland
I could see that that would be a good
reason to single night for different
treatments but I I hope to come back on
that particularly thank you before we
leave it it might be thought odd
perhaps that there's an additional
procedure available in respect of
Reserve matters when there is none in
respect of
other matters which might be equally
fundamental such as other restrictions
or incompatibility of a convention right
I think that
this is an issue of bifurcation
obviously that The Advocate generals
pointing to
but
because some are not all of the issues
concerning legislative competence could
be referred by me at this stage and some
can be referred Enlightenment
this this possibility arises because one
f is not directed specifically at the
present situation but is intended as a
sweep up provision allowing me to refer
questions relating to reserve matters
whenever they arise
and the fact that one f only provides a
sweep up in respect of questions of
preserved matters
is in a sense no reason to cut down the
extent the amplitude of the power it
confers and that would be effectively to
read down and rewrite the scheme but uh
the fact is that the opportunity is
there for this issue to be raised under
the Scotland act yes thank you yeah
distance in either direction from the
fact that
those words on which you rely are
included in one F which deals
first at least with evolved competence
which is a separate
concept defined elsewhere in the act
rather than being
1G
any other question
would there be an argument that one
reads it as part of
a provision dealing with
functions
rather than legislative
activity
so uh
quite sure was answer that question
I think it was I think the the
explanatory notes the notes and clauses
are quite helpful in that regard and
perhaps it would just be helpful to go
there but I think the point is that it
is
it was the legislation under the
Scotland Act was a fundamental change to
the Constitutional engagement of this
country and It produced uh in a sense
initiative Innovative procedures in
order to ensure that the parliament
acted within the confines of its the
powers given to it and the process
available under Earth
is one that allows the legislature the
ministers to be able to access the
courts foreign authorities ruling on a
default competence issue where it
relates to reserve matter and I think it
was just to ensure that it that any
Mentor that related to an issue of
reservation could be dealt with by this
court that there should be no
restriction on that
so the the
paragraph one enumerates a through to e
a whole series of questions about acts
of the Scottish Parliament and functions
of the Scottish ministers and whether or
not they breach the within devolved
competence or incompatible with
convention rights but if specifically is
the sweep up provision giving the
opportunity to raise any other question
arising under the acts to this court I
think that's a bit I mean the the point
has been been made that it doesn't sweep
up everything no that's right
I think we're looking just for some
assistance as to
whether there's any underlying Theory
why it focuses it sweeps up Reserve
matters but but not other matters for
instance the the convention right points
that's my Lord uh Lord Lloyd Jones
referred to
well I'll come back as I say I'll come
back on that particular Point
um it might be that we can find uh in
some background material a complete
answer to that question
foreign
just before you move on I think you said
that paragraph 1f was introduced at a
later stage in the bill progress
um after initial introduction and can I
were there any explanatory notes
specifically in relation to paragraph
one f
yeah or or was it just done in the
ordinary course of parliamentary
procedure without explanatory notes
being introduced alongside the amendment
there is there's no explanation note
only an internal government destruction
that we can supply a copy of that
yeah
it's puzzled about at the moment and
it's something why Parliament
um focused in one F on one particular
aspect of competence namely reserved
matters rather than other aspects of
companies all aspects of competitions
and as you see I'll try and find it yeah
I mean we do have to be a little bit
careful if it's an internal government
mode because that's not permissible a to
help us with interpret the act so I'd
offered to supply it but perhaps not
then but if I could suggest this perhaps
you can have a look at to see whether it
helps you make a submission to ask about
what the underlying reason might have
been rather than introducing it as
something that weakens I'll do that too
think about
I was coming on to deal with the
um
[Applause]
I didn't deal with the bifurcation point
and
at the next point in The Advocate
jailhouse case at paragraph 25 7
he has also submitted that
uh I haven't addressed my apartment
would have intended that legislation
could be subject to a reference prior to
introduction and potentially again
following enactment if its terms are
altered by Parliament
and he said it's said that there needs
to be an explanation for the potential
burden
it would impose he says on the finite
resources of this court
and
my position is the answer to this is
simple as the present peace
demonstrators demonstrates circumstances
can arise wherever reference to this
court cannot be made a bill cannot be
introduced and no determination of its
legality can be obtained from the court
so the existence of the catch-all
provision itself indicates that
Parliament recognized that not all
situations in which a reference to this
court will be appropriate could be
foreseen and given the rule of law
requires the proper interpretation of
legislation to be a matter for the
courts
like this point that I made before the
catch-all provision simply facilitates
the operation of the rule of law I mean
it's to come back to the same point but
to the same difficulty arises because
it's basically because of the mismatch
between section 31-1 which says a
statement's got to be given about
legislative competence and legislative
competence covers all matters within
um sorry 29 subsection 2 which isn't
just Reserve matters so mismatch between
section 31 subsection one and paragraph
one F in schedule six which just focuses
on reserve matters so I mean the point
the point you make in paragraph 26 of
your speaking though could have been
made more more generally but again
speaking for myself it's a bit of a
puzzle why yes
um it's a point that can be made about
Reserve matters but but not could have
been made but the doesn't arise in
relation to the other matters going to
legislative competence I understand the
point all right thank you
so what my point is
you said earlier also that you accepted
that if if something has been if a bill
has been referred
at this stage pre-introduction
then one couldn't refer for a different
law officer couldn't refer effectively
the same question to the court
using section 33
is that is that something that's
prevented by the act or is that just
that it would already have been decided
there would be no sense in doing so it
being decided I mean if I've come here
for a ruling on the competency of the
bill under the procedure I'm seeking at
the moment it would make no sense to
come back again under Section 33. yes I
I understand that as a practical answer
but is there a legal
[Music]
um
is there something as a matter of law
that rules that out
I don't think there is a matter of Law
and I think I've sought to explain that
that might be exceptional circumstances
that that would arise under I
I hoped I'd answered that previously in
itially
but
um what I see is
that there's actually no Prospect of a
provision in legislation
that's been introduced being referred
by any of the officers to or entertained
by this court again unless it's gone
undergoing a material Amendment during
its Passage through the Scottish
Parliament uh the and I see that the
concerns are raised by The Advocate
General about the burden on the finite
resources of this court are simply not
realistic
I know you're going to come on to deal
with discretion David
um presumably in the circumstances
postulated by my lady lady Rose
in the absence of any exceptional
circumstances to justify it this court
would say
that there was a discretion not to
address the same question again yes the
reference would be considered pointless
yes of course
so uh finally uh paragraph 25 is the
advocate Journal submitted that if I can
make the reference in these
circumstances so could he
but I think that that doesn't follow I
see in the present case as I've
explained in my written case
a question about Reserve matters arises
for me by virtue of the Scotland Acts
because of my functions in advising the
Scottish ministers I'm required to form
an opinion on whether or not the draft
Bill relates to reserved matter
The Advocate General is simply not in a
comparable situation
however my one might postulate this so
for example the prime minister of the UK
was considering whether to make an order
under Section 30 in respect of an
independence referendum or another
matter and wish to have an authoritative
ruling on whether or not such an order
was necessary or whether the Scottish
Parliament already had legislative
competence in respect of the matter such
a situation might be one which The
Advocate General or indeed the Attorney
General might have jurisdiction and
consider it appropriate to make
reference to this court but he is in a
very different position from me because
of the particular responsibilities that
I have in law by virtue of the Scotland
Acts
and in relation to the second issue
paused which is whether or not the
question arises by virtue of the ACT
at paragraph 26 of The Advocate
General's case he submits that there's
no Reserve matter arising by virtue of
the act and therefore paragraph 1A is
not satisfied on its own terms
The Advocate General's argument is that
the statement required by section 31-1
is to be made by a minister and no part
of the Lord advocate's rule is
prescribed under the ACT
uh We've touched on this in discussion
but I see he's wrong for the following
reasons
firstly the words arising by virtue of
this act used in schedule 6 1af on their
natural and ordinary meaning require
only that the Scotland act causes an
issue about reserved matters to arise
furthermore the first part of schedule
61a refers to whether a function is
exercisable
the wording as well as similar wording
in one B to D we explain that the
subsequent General sweep upwards that
refer to any other question arising by
virtue of the ACT are not limited to the
exercise of functions conferred by the
ACT
if as The Advocate General contended 1A
was restricted to questions that arise
in the course of decisions and are
explicitly prescribed by the Scotland
Act
then the scope of one life would be very
narrow and potentially non-existent
and The Advocate General does not
provide any examples of decisions that
would be prescribed
by the Scotland act that could give rise
to questions about reserved matters to
which he contains schedule 6 1 8 and 34
could apply
I see that such a narrow construction
would have significant implications for
schedule 6 in general
schedule 6 is not principally concerned
with references to this course
it's principally concerned with
devolution's issues that arise in legal
proceedings in the United Kingdom's
course
and the broad amplitude of one f is apt
to sweep up all issues about reserved
matters that could arise in legal
proceedings and then bring them within
the scope of schedule 6.
however if one if was read very narrowly
in the manner contended for by The
Advocate General
driven by proceed need to limit the
circumstances in which references to
this court could be made pursuant to
paragraph 34 so that it's understood as
referring only to decisions prescribed
by the ACT
the effect would be that the legitimate
questions about reserved matters could
arise in legal provision proceedings but
the provisions of schedule 6 Parts 2304
would not be engaged because it could
not be shown that the issue arose
pursuant to a decision prescribed by the
acts and I see that simply wasn't
parliament's intention
just as a matter of interest that the
Northern Ireland act
um
but that's the same approach in to
Devolution issues yes the um
it it paragraph one is schedule 10.
has a number of sub paragraphs dealing
with uh competence issues of competence
and then there's the sweep up at the end
is any question arising under this act
about accepted or reserved matters yes
I don't know the explanation is as a
family likeness yes yes well I I I'll
certainly try and resolve the the
question over lunch or
which came first
this is
beside each other in the statute book
yes uh the Northern Ireland Act is
chapter 47 and the Scotland Act is
chapter 46.
so um and I'm so sorry to press on this
but it might be worth checking in
relation to Northern Ireland act since
I've seen that they were more or less
progressing through Parliament at about
the same time whether there are any ex
public explanatory notes in relation to
the
um the distinction format that was used
in that act I'll do that
so just uh to be clear then in the
circumstances of this reference a
question relating to a reserve matter
arises by virtue of the art because it's
about Reserve matters and reserved
matters exist only by virtue of the
Scotland Act
in relation to section 31 it is
necessary for a member of the Scottish
government introducing a bill to make a
statement that the bill is within
competence
and that's extended to any member
introducing a bill by section 6 of the
Scotland Act 2012.
it is natural and obvious that Law
Officers will advise on that question
the requirement for law officer's advice
is now embodied in the Scottish
ministerial Court
which has been recognized in by this
court in the uncrc case and there's
reference there am I speaking up to that
particular case
and the fact that as part of the
safeguards arising from the Scotland Act
The Advocate General submits the
contrary to the true basis for the
reference is the creation of a
self-imposed hurdle to section 311
derived from the Scottish ministerial
Court
however the code reflects the safeguards
built into the Scotland Act
and even if the code didn't require me
as Lord Advocate to clear draft Bill's
prior to introduction I would need to
advise on whether the bills would be
within legislative competence
finally The Advocate General Reliance on
the reference by the attorney general
for Northern Ireland of devolution
issues to the Supreme Court case in 2020
I see that his Reliance theory is also
misplaced that case is not analogous to
the present situation
in that case it was held that the
preparation of lists of postcodes for
commencing welfare Provisions was too
remote from the question of whether the
provisions themselves were compatible
with the European convention on human
rights to give rise to a Devolution
issue
in the present case the question whether
the draft Bill relates to reserved
matter arises directly and squarely for
determination by the officer
the Lord have good
the there is a separate issue raised by
The Advocate General as to whether or
not there is a Lacuna if no reference
can be made
and he says that there's no Lacuna or
imperfect imperfect imperfection rather
in the statutory scheme if legislation
cannot be introduced by the parliament
because the Lord Advocate doesn't have
the requisite degree of confidence that
would be within competence and the issue
cannot be referred to this court for an
authority to ruling
The Advocate General submits that if the
Scottish Law Officers consider the
provision to be outside competence the
UK Parliament would not have intended
the time of this court to be taken up
resolving it
my position is there's no basis for this
assertion as to parliament's intention
it's far more likely and in accordance
with the rule of law that Parliament
intended that this court would have
jurisdiction to provide an authoritative
determination of issues of law that
arise under the Scotland act in
circumstances where I consider that a
reference to this court is appropriate
and in the public interest
the fact that Parliament intended this
court to be capable of resolving issues
of law properly arise
and the Lord Advocate should I say not
be put in the position of the ultimate
Arbiter with no ability to seek a ruling
of this court where appropriate it's
reflected in the scheme of the Scotland
act in the very Broad and legally
negative Provisions for the Lord
Advocate and other other officers to
refers questions directly to this court
and I say there's no reason to think
that this will overburden this court
the fact that the ability to make
references directly to this court is
limited to specified Law Officers and in
the present context to the Lord Advocate
pursuant to the retained function that I
have under the Scotland Act
provides assurance that the references
will be made sparingly and properly
and this is such this is the first
reference
by a lord advocate in 23 years
this court also retains the power to
ensure that references are appropriate
but coming on then to deal with the
question of the Court's discretion about
allowing this matter this reference to
be heard the advocate Journal submits
that even if this court has jurisdiction
if she'd refuse to determine the
reference in the discretion in its
discretion on the basis of its advisory
abstract hypothetical and premature
[Applause]
I see that simply not the correct
characterization of the reference
it is of course correct that the
reference is advisory but that is the
nature of the reference procedure
in the Supreme Court of Canada
in the case of reference recession of
Quebec which I quote in my speaking note
Court said on a direct reference it's
not acting in its traditional
adjudicative capacity and it's not
engaged in the disposition of Rights
for the same reason the Supreme Court
explained that a reference process
inherently involves the determination of
issues that otherwise may not be ripe
for a decision because they've not
Arisen in the context of a legal dispute
that is the case in this context since a
reference pursuant to sex to paragraph
34 of schedule 6 can only be made in
relation to issues that are not the
subject of legal proceedings
despite such inherent features of a
reference procedure this reference is
made to obtain an authoritative ruling
on a concrete legal issue that I see has
crystallized that question is not
premature it is a question that section
31 of the Scotland act requires the
minister in charge of a bill to ask and
answer and on which the Lord Advocate
must advise
the answer to the question will have
concrete effects it will determine
whether the draft bill is introduced to
the Scottish Parliament or not and
Trigger the statutory Provisions
applicable to the enactment of primary
legislation under the Scotland Act
I don't shy away from the fact that it's
less than ideal that this court should
be asked to examine a question relating
to a provision to be included in a bill
that has not yet been passed by the
Scottish Parliament and not accompanied
by some of the associated materials that
often accompany modern legislation
but the reference relates to a legal
question that the Scotland act requires
persons in charge of the bill to post
themselves and respect of which is the
responsibility of the lord lord Advocate
to advise ministers upon
if ministers and the Lord Advocate must
consider and reach a view on whether a
prison would be within legislative
competence without those materials there
is no reason in logic or in principle
why this court should not be able to do
so in a proper case
so in his arguments on discretion The
Advocate General relies on the case of
yaland against the Secretary of State
Forex exiting the European Union
but I see that case provides no support
for his position
I make a number of points in my speaking
notes the court in the island emphasize
that as a general rule the courts are
concerned with adjudicating on issues of
law that have already arisen
that general rule is observed in this
case as the issue of law has already
arisen predetermination
the Lord Advocate must determine in
order to advise ministers for the
purposes of section 31 of the Scotland
Act
the court in yaland went on to States in
a passage in which The Advocate General
pleases particular lines that when
issues of law depend on future
legislation it will generally not be
appropriate to make rulings on questions
of law until the precise terms of the
legislation are wrong
however in this case the legal issues
that fall to be determined does not
depend upon the terms of future
legislation
it depends entirely on the terms of the
draft bill
the legal issue posed for ministers by
section 31 relates to a draft bill which
they intend to introduce not to United
legislation
similarly in relation to the comments
made by The Advocate General in relation
to the council general for Wales against
Secretary of State for business and
energy case
uh fair to my speaking notes
I see his case doesn't support a
submission that the legal issue is
abstract premature or hypothetical
in that case the council general for
Wheels sought a declaration as to the
powers of the senate in the absence of
even legislative proposals
the Court held until legislation is
proposed it would not
be clear whether such legislation would
fall within a reserve matter
it was better the Court held that the
issue be tested by reference to proposed
Senate legislation rather than in the
abstract
that as this is unexceptional but has no
relevance to the present case where the
legislation proposed
is um is proposed and a concrete
decision under the Scotland act Falls to
be made in respect of it
and thereafter The Advocate General
relies on the case of kittens
in his recent case
in which the Lord president identified a
number of circumstances as justifying
not entertaining the challenge at that
in that case
said that most of these apply with the
same Force to this present reference
there were five reasons given by the
Lord president and Keating see where
there was a draft bill that may or may
not be introduced depending upon the
government formed as a consequence of
the election
if the introduced draft Bill may or may
not be in the form that it was before
the court
the bill may or may not be passed at all
or in the same form
and the UK government may or may not be
prepared to make an order permitting a
referendum pursuant to section 30 of the
Scotland Act and have passed without
such an order having been made the bill
would likely to be referred to the
Supreme Court pursuant to section 33.
so contrary to The Advocate General's
case none of these reasons apply to this
reference indeed rather than providing a
basis for refusing to entertain the
reference
they demonstrate why it's not
hypothetical or premature
so by reference to each of the reasons
set out in part in one to five by the
Lord president as have listed in my
notes firstly
the election has concluded that the
Scottish government will introduce the
draft bill that is before this court if
cleared by me
all relevant provisions of the bill
material to the Devolution issue
referred will be introduced in the form
that they are in before this court
whilst the bill may or may not be passed
a prior issue arises which
is the need for the statement pursuant
to section 31 of the Scotland act which
depends upon the draft Bill and its
current form notice enacted form
fourthly the UK government has made it
clear that opposed to the referendum and
the legal issue will not be referred to
this court post-enactment because the
bill cannot presently be introduced so
that stage will just not be reached
therefore I say tasted against the
reasons given by the Lord president in
keatings the present reference is not
academic or premature
and I see The Advocate General
submissions to the fact that this court
should refuse to entertain the reference
should therefore be rejected
so I move on then to deal with my
submissions on legislative competence
and I propose to take these submissions
under five broad headings
firstly I will address the draft bill
secondly I'll address the relevant case
law on the test to be applied under
Section 29 2 and 3 on the issue relates
to in terms of the Scotland gate
thirdly I will address the argument to
the fact that the draft Bill does not
relate to the union and is therefore not
within it does relate to the union of
sorry does relate to Union is and is
therefore not within the competence of
the Scottish Parliament
fourthly I'll address the opposing case
to the effect the draft Bill does not
relate to the union and is therefore
within the competence of the Scottish
Parliament as I've done in our written
case and recognizing the thrust of the
general submissions I propose to spend
more time on this argument that the bill
is within competence
fifthly I will much more briefly address
the competing arguments on whether the
bill relates to the United Kingdom
Parliament and so I now propose to turn
to the draft bill
so
holding a referendum is not a reserved
matter
part of B3 of schedule 5 that deals with
elections doesn't reserve the holding of
res of referendums so in that respect I
refer to the authority at tab 1
Electronic folder page 206-208
and of course the basic structure of the
Scotland Act is that the Scottish
Parliament has plenary powers to
legislate on all matters other than
those which are specifically reserved it
is a reserved power model
details General provision for the
conduct and regulation of referendums
has been made by the Scottish parliament
in the referendum Scotland Act 2020.
and that is produced at volume 3 tab 37
electronic folder page 2173
so nobody disputes that such provision
is within the legislative competence of
the Scottish Parliament
in relation to the ACT
dealing quickly with the provisions that
are relevant section one relates to
scope
section two to the questions that are
posed in the referendum
four deals with the eligibility of those
who are entitled to vote
and section 6 and schedule 1 make
detailed provision about the manner of
voting such as absent or Postal votes
and registration
so that having been
proposed bill is in fact relatively
short
and we can see that at page ef13 of the
electronic bundle
so the bill itself
Begins by narrating the purpose of the
legislation
under section one
to make provision for ascertaining the
views of the people of Scotland on
whether Scotland should be an
independent country
[Applause]
provision is then made for the question
to be posed
the ballot paper and the date of the
referendum
that's dealt with in section two
and the franchise is contained in
section three
the question in the proposed build is
the same question that was paused in the
2014 referendum
2020 Act is then applied although any
specific qualifications are yet to be
identified and the standard final form
of Provisions are to be included in
paragraphs five through sections five
through to eight
the former form of ballot paper is set
out in the schedule
and notably no provision is made for the
effect of any result of the referendum
that is the referendum is not
self-executing it simply produces a
result
so no legal consequences automatically
are necessarily flawed from any results
this is a draft bill it has not yet been
introduced but it is in final form with
the exception of immaterial details
it is in the form that is Lord Advocate
would be asked to provide advice to the
Scottish government on as to whether or
not it is within competence
The Advocate General has drawn attention
to the fact that there are presently no
accompanying documents such as draft
explanatory memoranda
that is true
but my consideration consideration of a
draft bill is not always informed by
such documents
when such documents are available indeed
they're not always in final form
in any event
the bill is obviously very short and
straightforward
its purpose is set out in the terms of
the bill itself and it is in material
the same terms as that which was
authorized in the 2014 referendum
so looking then to the relevant legal
framework and the powers of the Scottish
Parliament
it is a body of case law concerning the
interpretation and application of some
of the central aspects of the Scotland
Act
Land Act introduced a fundamental
sections 1 to 12 of the ACT constituted
a Scottish Parliament as democratically
elected legislature from whom among from
among whom members of the Scottish
ministers are drawn to form the Scottish
government
Scottish ministers have drawn along with
Scottish Law Officers to form the
government and to which those ministers
and Law Officers are accountable
the creation of the Scottish Parliament
which and the the nature of it was
referred to by Lord hope in the case of
BH against Lord Advocate
and that the reference I would wish to
meet there is a paragraph 30.
I don't need to turn up the authority
it's a ef-3154 tab 53
of the authorities and he said the
fundamental constitutional nature of the
settlement that was achieved by the
Scotland act that's how you refer to it
and all members of the Court agreed with
this part of his judgment
in aksar the president this quote Lord
read that paragraph 153
which is Authority for
ef-517
explained quoting Lord Roger an R
against hme paragraph 16 that the
Scotland Act is a major constitutional
measure which altered the government of
the United Kingdom
the status of the Scottish Parliament
was described by the president Lord Reid
in the uncr C Bill reference at
paragraph seven
at ef-904
at 9 11 Authority tab 15.
he said this the Scottish Parliament
is a democratically elected legislature
with a mandate to meet laws for Scotland
it has plenary powers within the limits
of its legislative competence
but it does not enjoy the sovereignty of
the crown in Parliament
rules delimiting its legislative
competence are found in section 29 and
of schedules four and five to the
Scotland act to which the courts must
give effect
and Parliament also has an unlimited
power to make laws for Scotland a part
of which the legislation of the Scottish
Parliament cannot affect
section 28 7 of the Scotland Act
the Scotland act must be interpreted in
the same way as any other statute
the courts have regardless aims to
achieve a constitutional assessment and
therefore recognize the importance of
giving the Scotland act a consistent and
predictable interpretation so that the
Scottish Parliament as has a coherent
stable and workable system within which
to exercise its legislative power
that is achieved by interpreting the
rules as to competence in the Scotland
act according to the ordinary meaning of
the words used
in acts are against General Insurance
company against Lord Advocate 2011 at
paragraph 4146
again Lord reads
that electronic folder page 515
emphasized not only the breadth of the
Scottish parliament's plenary Powers but
also that it's for the Scottish
Parliament to determine the political
and other considerations that it wishes
to take account in exercising its
plenary powers
Lord Viet said within the limit set by
section 29 2 however its power to
legislate is as amples it could possibly
be
there is no indication in Scotland Act
of any specific purposes which are a
guide which are to guide it in its law
making or any specific matters to which
it is have to have regard
even if it may be said at the highest
level of generality that the Scotland
acts Scottish parliament's Power had
been conferred upon it for the purpose
of good government of Scotland that
would not limit its powers
leaves it to the Scottish Parliament
itself as a democratically elected
legislature to determine its own policy
goals it has to decide for itself the
purposes for which this legislative
powers should be used and the political
and other considerations which are
relevant to the exercise of those powers
so the limits on letters of competence
of the Scottish parliament are set down
in section 29a of the Scottish of the
Scotland act and while there are common
law limits to the legislative competence
of the parliament which were referred to
in the case of AXA at paragraph 153 by
Lord Reid those limits are not relevant
for present purposes
but turning up section 29 which is an
authorities tab 1 EF page 129
uh the section 29 provides so far as
relevant for president purposes
in subsection
one
that an act of the Scottish Parliament
is not law so far as any provisions of
the ACT is outside the legislative
competence of the parliament
a provision is outside that legislative
competence so far as any of the
following paragraphs apply
and that is B it relates to reserve
matters
a subparagraph three the section 29 goes
on to State for the purposes of this
section the question whether a provision
of an act of the Scottish Parliament
relates to reserved matter is to be
determined subject to subsection 4 by
reference to the purpose of the
provision having regard among other
things to its effect in all the
circumstances
in subparagraph four it provides a
provision which would otherwise not
relate to reserve matters but which
makes modifications of Scott's private
law or Scott's criminal law as it
applies to reserve matters is to be
treated as relating to reserved matters
until the purpose of the provision is to
meet the law in question apply
consistently to research matters or
otherwise
and at subsection five it says subject
section one is subject to section 30
subsection six
so the statutory concept of relates to
is thus afforded a specific legal
definition from
and more restrictive than its ordinary
meaning
and I'll address the case law on that
term the term relates to
in due course
section 31 which is over the page at
ef131
did you get that point from from section
29 that the term relates to or the
concept relates to has a special meaning
yes so my lady I read it in terms of the
provision but also I I get that from
case law that I'll come on to refer to
that were you saying that comes from
subsection four is that what subsection
three I said
so for the purposes of this section
I think we're not confirmed the
subsection foreign
yes that's exactly right concerned with
three yes
so just to see that the question of the
subsection three
says for the purposes of this section a
question with a provision of an act of
the Scottish Parliament relates to
reserved matter is to be determined
subject to subsection four by reference
to the purpose of the provision having
regard among other things to its effect
in all the circumstances I think that's
been described as a term of Art in such
little cases where the court has looked
extensively at the meaning of relates to
in the uh in Scotland Act
uh in relation to section 30 subsection
one
that gives effect to schedule five and I
was I was looking at that
and
it says uh so section 30.
it says that uh it's headed legislative
competence
and section 30 subsection one
explains that schedule five which
defines reserved matters shall have
effect
and for present purposes
the relevant reservations are found in
paragraph one of schedule five
and schedule five
is at EF
-184
and provides
as follows
in paragraph one
oh it's ef-183 to 184 paragraph ones and
at one eight three
so uh paragraph one says the following
aspects of the Constitution are reserved
at 1B the union of the kingdoms of
Scotland and England and one see the
parliament of the United Kingdom
and I've simply emphasize from looking
at this the following points
the Constitution itself
is not a reserved matter the
Constitution's simplicitor is not
reserved it's only specified aspects of
that
and the language used in one B reserves
the union of the kingdoms of Scotland
and England
and I've noted in the written case at
paragraph 100 to 102 that there is a
peculiarity in that the kingdoms of
Scotland and England have been
superseded by the United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland
and one C refers to the parliament of
the UK but I don't suggest anything
turned on that just a particular
peculiarity of the legislation
so in relation to the case law on
relates to
the approach to the term relates to was
summarized by this court in its judgment
the UK withdrawal from the European
Union legal continuity Scotland Bill uh
case 2018
at paragraph 27
it's Authority 11 at EF page 836 and I
think it's helpful to look at paragraph
27 of the continuity Bill keys
paragraph 27 is at page EF 835
and on to page ef-836
and it provides the court said at
paragraph 27
in order to relate to reserved matter
a provision of a Scottish bill must have
more than a loose or consequential
connection with it and references
they're made to Martin against most Lord
Walker at paragraph 49 and to the
Imperial tobacco against Lord Advocate
Keys 2012 at paragraph 26
it said that Lord hope observed that the
question required one
first to understand the scope of the
matter which was reserved and secondly
to determine by reference to the purpose
of the provisions under challenge having
regard among other things to their
effect and all the circumstance
whether those Provisions relate to the
reserved matter
the purpose of an enactment for this
purpose May extend beyond its legal
effect but it is not the same thing as
its political motivation
so in paragraph 27 the reference was
made to release to means more than a
loose and consequential connection
citing Martin against most
and that the question requires first to
understand the nature of the matter
which is reserved
to determine by reference to the purpose
of the provision
having regard to its effect
whether the provision relates to a
reserved matter
the purpose May extend beyond legal
effects but it's not the same as
political motivation
so first that is the general framework
I submit that taking the case law as a
whole
there is doubt about two matters
the precise relevance of connection to
the statutory test set out in section
293
so this precise relevance of connection
and secondly the nature and degree of
the connection that must exist before
the possibility arises that a provision
relates to a reserved matter
this isn't really all
and it's coming from the uh this is
entirely Lord Manson's judgment in the
Welsh case isn't it it is in part
relating to Lord mance's judgment but I
I also and to demonstrate that he's not
in any sense an outlier actually would
make reference to what my lord said in
the inner house in Imperial tobacco in
fact I think consistent with what Lord
mance's approach was and indeed what
Lord Brody said in the inner house in
the Imperial tobacco case because I
think when you compare what was said by
my Lord in the inner house in Imperial
tobacco to what was eventually
determined by this court in which Lord
hope gave the Judgment there was very
little difference to draw between what
my lord said there and what was
ultimately determined so I don't I think
there may be an issue between you and
Sir James in relation to
where the Lord Mance yes
in the Walsh asbestos case was actually
supporting a test of direct connection
yes that's exactly so I'm going to come
on to deal with that but it's in my
point is that Lord man says there's no
sense an outlier in that regard and uh
we can see that what he said is
consistent with
what my Lord has leader said in the
inner house and Imperial tobacco but
also consistent with the way in which
this court determined the continuity
Bill case
and the underlying ratio and the
underlying rationale for the
determination in legal continuity Bill
case so just dealing with that point
then
um
the starting point I would suggest is
Martin against most
uh in which was determined in 2010
and that's in the authorities at Tab 3
electronic folder page 382
and a paragraphs portal 4 to 405.
Lord Walker
there
refer to the difficulties of defining
necessarily in Fairly General and
abstract terms permitted or prohibited
areas of legislative activity
and how forms of words have come to be
recognized as indicating a more or less
proximate or direct or crucial
connection with tuna proposed enactment
and an area of legislative activity
at paragraph 49 electronic folder page
406-407
Lord Walker said that relates to
suggests more than a loose and
consequential connection
and that the reference to purpose
reinforces that
hear the word connection appears to be
used as simply shorthand for and not
separate from or additional two the
statutory test of relates to imposed by
the relevant Devolution legislation
so the effect of 29 3
that we've looked at is that the purpose
of a legislative instrument that must
relate to reserve matter is the purpose
that must relate to the reserved matter
is therefore necessary to identify the
purpose with precision
the second aspect of 2093 is that it
requires a particular attention to
effect
that is not a separate test
but essentially asthma it's mandating
that the purpose is derived with
particular attention to the effect of a
provision
essentially what powers duties and
rights that confers
so the fact that the purpose of the
legislation is Central to the question
whether the legislation relates to
reserved matter was made clear by Lord
hope in Imperial tobacco
at a paragraph 16
and we see that at electronic folder
Pages 61 and 6 for all
um
and uh at paragraph 16 Lord hope said
it will of course be necessary to
identify the purpose of the provision if
the challenge is brought under Section
29 2B on the ground that it relates to
reserve matter
bearing in mind that the phrase relates
to indicates something more than a loose
or consequential connection
that's also what was said in the in the
same terms similar terms in the
Christian Institute case which is at Tab
10 at paragraph 30 which is an
electronic folder page 791
so just looking at the Christian
Institute case Tab 10 paragraph 30
ef-791
they're the court said
whether a provision relates to reserve
matter in the extent in the sense
explained by Lord Walker is determined
by reference to the purpose of the
provision in question
that purpose is to be ascertained having
regard to the effect of the provision
among relevant matters
as was said in relation to similar
Provisions in the government of Wales
act
2006 in
attorney general for England and Wales
against Council Jennifer Williams
paragraph 50
as section 50 requires the purpose of
the provision to be examined it is
necessary to look not merely at what can
be discerned from an objective
consideration of the effect of its terms
so
further guidance on the nature or degree
of connection that must exist between a
reserved matter and the purpose of a
provision before it can be said that the
provision relates to the reserve matter
that was as uh I see done in the case in
remedical costs for asbestos diseases
wheel spinning case 2015 UK Supreme
Court Authority tab 9 Electronics order
page 716 and that Authority is also in
volume one
the the asbestos case the medical cost
for asbestos diseases will spill Wheels
Bill case was designed to impose
liabilities on persons compensating
victims of asbestos related disease and
their insurers for NHS costs
it was designed to compensate NHS Wales
for the cost of asbestos disease
the key question was whether the
government of walesight provided
legislative competence
and at that time the ACT operated on a
conferred Powers model rather than a
retained pers model
and the then Welsh assembly only had the
Paris expressly conferred on it and one
of the competencies conferred was the
organization and funding of the National
Health Service
the Government wields Act permitted
legislation to be made by the assembly
that related to a conferred power
and the relevant statutory Provisions
are set out in paragraphs 11 and 12 of
the keys at electronic holders 728-729
and that's in volume one tab nine
so the paragraphs are 11 and 12 728
729 of the electronic folder
it is helpful just to quickly look at
the statutory Provisions because they do
assist in understanding the business
upon which the court decided the case
seven to eight and uh
so the heading is competence under
Section 10845 paragraph 11 and then over
the page it says that uh under Section
1083 a provision is only within the
legislative competence if it falls
within section four or five
and the provision Falls within section
1084 if it relates to one of the
subjects listed under any of the
headings in part one of schedule 7 and
doesn't ball within any of the
exceptions specified in that part of the
schedule
um
a provision Falls within section 1085
if it provides for the enforcement of a
provision
of that or any other Act of the assembly
which Falls within subsection 4 or a
provision of an assembly measure or it's
otherwise appropriate for making
provision effective or is otherwise
incidental too or consequential on such
a provision
the relevant matter was specified in
part one of schedule seven
and it was placed under heading health
and Health Services
and a specific competence confared is
listed there
and it ends in where it begins promotion
of Health along Seas of areas which
compared competencies given summarized
at the End by organization funding of
the National Health Service
there are exceptions that are listed
also Under The Heading health and Health
Services that are listed also in
paragraph 12 of the decided case
and is there a provision similar to
section 29
yeah subsection three yes that's right
there is yes
um so I
I have a particular reference to say
paragraph 25 I think Lord man deals with
that
yeah
he says that um section 1087 provides
that for the purposes of this section
the question for their provision of an
act of the assembly reports to one or
more as the subjects listed in part one
of schedule seven are false within
anything exception specified is to be
determined by reference to the purpose
of the provision having regard among
other things to its effects in all the
circumstances
and I think he says that the way in
which that has to be approached in
relation to Wheels Act is exactly the
same we it should be approached in
relation to these the Scottish provision
so at paragraph 24
Lord manth described the
key question
which is on page 734 is whether on the
Assumption I'm making the government
government will that act provides
legislative competence for the
imposition of liabilities on
compensators and insurers and to this I
therefore turn
I've already touched on what he dealt
with at paragraph 25
and what the majority of this court
therefore made clear is that the
approach under the government whale side
should be identical to that ticking
under the Scotland Act
um
we know though as a result of the 2017
Wales act they moved from a conferred
Parish model to a reserved powers model
so in this case Lord mans in paragraph
twice 25 cites the Imperial tobacco case
and the comments by Lord Walker in
Martin against most that we've already
looked at
and then for since it was clear that the
purpose of the legislation and issue was
to reimburse the nhas the critical
question or critical issue was whether
this sufficiently closely related to
funding the NHS was it sufficiently
close to the conferred power granted
bill which to impose liabilities and
compensators under Shooters was then
assessed according to the propositions
set out by Lord mans in his assessment
of what the meaning of the Confederate
power was
and he concluded at paragraph 26
that the operation
and funding of the nfhs clearly cannot
permit generally General money raising
and hypothecation for the NHS is in
substance nor different from a general
charge boosting the Welsh government's
resources
and doesn't change the conclusion in one
and he also noted that paragraph 28 that
the Welsh ministers couldn't raise money
in any way they chose even if the only
purpose for which the monies raised
could be the Welsh NHS
he said to come with incompetence any
money reason would have to be and this
is in paragraph 27 morally more directly
connected with the service provided and
its funding
and simply raising money which can be
used to fund the NHS could not
constitute a sufficiently close
connection
compared to for example in this case
the direct connection of a prescription
charge
so lordman's
therefore concluded that in this case of
the charges posed including those within
section 2 of the bill that the court was
concerned with
the argument would have to be that a
sufficient connection could be found in
the actual or alleged wrongdoing that
led to compensator making a compensation
payment to or in respect of a sufferer
from and asbestos related to disease
in his this case he explained that this
could only be an indirect loose or
consequential connection the inevitably
adopting Lord Walker's language and
using those as well that's right yes
so I see this about the reasoning of
Lord mans in these paragraphs I see it
is directed to the degree or closeness
of the connection between the purpose
and effect of the legislation and the
matter of funding the NHS
Lord man's reasoned that the purpose was
not sufficiently close to the funding of
the NHS and it was only indirectly
related to the funding of the NHS
for that reason he said legislation was
not with incompetence
and so in relation to Lord Mance I say
at one end of the spectrum was a law
which had the purpose and effect of
raising money to cover the course of the
NHS
perhaps a law unrelated to health
this Lord Mance explained could not
constitute a sufficiently close
connection to funding the nhas and at
the other end of the spectrum were
prescription charges where there is a
direct connection to benefiting from a
service and contributing to its funding
I see that it's clear that Lord Mance
was directly concerned with the
closeness of connection and whether it
was direct or indirect
and
Lord mans then turned to the facts of
the case and asked whether a law
targeting
compensators and insurers is
sufficiently closely related to funding
the NHS service
and he referred
to the fact that here
there is the wrongdoing relating to
asbestos disease
however in the critical part of his
reasoning
he stated that that is at best an
indirect loose or consequential
connection
in this sentence he very deliberately
and expressly modifies Lord Walker's
language to emphasize the needs for a
direct connection and to exclude a
consequential connection
that this was a Crux of the reasoning is
clear not only from the paragraphs in
paragraph the preceding paragraphs often
27 but also from the following sentence
we refers to persons having no other
direct Connection in law with the NHS
so I say therefore that the Welsh
asbestos case held at the connection
between the purpose of a measure
and in that case a conferred power must
be close and direct
it's not sufficient that its General aim
or subject matter concerns the subject
matter of a conferred power
the Welsh asbestos law concerned funding
the NHS in the sense that it would raise
money for the NHS
but that was insufficiently directly
related to the conferred power of
organization and funding of the National
Health Service
I see not only is this requirement for
directors relevant to the issue as to
whether an advisory referendum is
related to Union but it also provides an
illustration of a case where it was not
sufficient that the law was concerned
with the same subject matter but lack
direct connection
uh so The Advocate General at paragraph
59 in his submission submits that the
case does not purport to create any
different approach from Imperial tobacco
and nothing in the Judgment of Lord
Nance indicates that a requirement of
direct connection is imposed but I see
that is not right
for a number of reasons I see uh it's
just afterwards shall we come to this
after the shorter Journal yes thank you
about two o'clock
[Applause]